oh yeah look at the bottoms of my feet
hopefully I haven't stepped anything bad
welcome everyone Beth Morosky as always
Jason O'Malley creeper in the corner we
got Britney insured helping us out say
hello Britney I hope you enjoy my I wore
a shirt with you know tiny little palm
trees
cuz it's 80 degrees today that's right
let's hear it for the west coast and the
earth dying that's right yeah and the
futures FEMA I love what it also says
that's right this is a sweatshirt that's
not a sweater that's clearly a
sweatshirt that's kind of screwed up can
you make the chat bigger thanks for
joining us we're gonna play a little
game called attack on Titan 2 and this
game is based on an anime called attack
on Titan and in this anime there's a
bunch of naked giant beasts humanoid
beasts taking over the earth who like to
eat people and it's our job to destroy
them and we're gonna do it today so
let's get going
like any other day it's just a normal
good old Titan killing hump day you know
how's everybody doing hey cobble believe
oh that's so loud my god good lord
looking good guys I can get yourself
he's music I got caught in the rain last
Thursday LOL wow did it get so cold i
don't know la weather tuck naked hugo
deus naked giant piece just watch this
beginning it's gonna blow your funky
little mine have you ever heard of this
i wear look at this look at these giant
crazy naked what's happening here this
is insane
she's sleeping he's drinking coffee
she's crying she's got a turtleneck but
I will say I played a little bit of this
game already and you have this cool like
soup thing that lets you be like
spider-man so you kind of jump all
around it's incredibly awesome yeah
syn rise you know I've never seen an
attack on Titan I do I do right off the
YouTube comments as well I read off both
twitch and YouTube comments so in your
face coolest gamers the best thing on
YouTube thanks for tonight Killa tonight
I'm terrible at fortnight by the way war
night is a very difficult thing oh this
is a new thing too if you guys are in
the twitch chat there's this thing
called the stay hydrated bot which tells
people to drink water and it just says
welcome to or whatever
yeah buddy oh yeah yeah so you can
toggle your hydration reminders so every
hour you're playing I played on Saturday
night for like three hours because I
have nothing to do outside of the next
time I meet friends I leave my house so
I stream for three hours and it kept
coming up and it was really depressing
because it was like oh I've been
streaming for another hour and it says
like drink twenty milliliters of water
and it's just like I chose whiskey cuz
it's a more depressing so stay hydrated
bot you shot yourself in the foot story
so far two years ago the armored Titan
robbed me of both family and home now
I'm enrolled in the hundred and fourth
together with my corpse mates or is it
corps mates Corps mates sounds better I
enjoy a daily regimen of brutal training
all this for a revenge till I graduate
the Corps enter the scouts and slay that
armored abomination I tend to continue
these writings well there's nothing
better than reading someone's personal
journal Oh Eureka thank you my friends
and I loved your an RJ show on Monday
that's right my friend RJ and I do a
podcast called RJ and play suck at girls
and we had a live show at the meltdown
which went really well and its really
interesting telling someone details of
your private life it's way different
saying it out into a microphone that it
is saying it to fifty people in a room
which is horrifying so thank you to
everybody who came out here's to an hour
of training listen Matt
Sims I don't need that lid although I
will say if there's too much talking
we're just gonna scratch this and you
know I would just want to fight Titans
sunrise you said this is a great idea I
always forget to drink water that's why
my skin is quite dry I know I think
maybe I need like a stay hydration bot
in my life period okay he Annie Ariana
one thing this game did which I really
liked
was it just through you right into
attacking a giant Titan which I enjoy
and these RPGs it's like let's get to
the meat you know what I'm saying let's
get to the naked Titan Neyland hey
slayer darth what's up kind of is he
eaten by a Titan Conan is it Titan how
about that I don't wanna go back the
plaza god damn it
sexy Eren to start the day you that's
not how you spell my name and I'm not
sexy so that's yeah that's right we all
saw you choose a female character yeah
this is not Beth's Beth would not look
guys I'm allowed to be a female
character right open your minds it's
2018 the futures female the presents
female the past not as female I hope the
futures working yeah exactly
all right we don't I know guys I know
the story is important but this is also
boring we don't need to we don't need an
hour of me reading what Mina says don't
let it get to you dude
Madison wheels who doesn't like a giant
Conan yeah you know redundant to say
it's just Conan yeah yeah
and also Conan has I will say Conan has
a lot he's a lot in common with the
Titan he's huge mmm-hmm he's so pale you
can see his insides so it's kind of like
he eats people human flesh he feasts on
it
a lot of people don't understand that
they think he's like on some Hollywood
diet
no it's he's a cannibal he feeds on
human flesh it's really interesting
actually a lot of our celebrity guests
don't even make it out alive no or
without like all their fingers you know
believe pay attention to people who've
been on Conan a lot of times they're
missing body parts just here and there
but Conan never gets greedy enough you
know to like they say like you know you
can you can shear a sheep as many times
as you want you can skin it only once
and that's kind of how Conan go it's
coming in the cannibal goes he just
takes a little pieces off people he
doesn't you know cuz he wants the guests
to come back he wants John Krasinski
come back he's not gonna you know eat
him right now exactly exactly
okay oh boy Wow alright sideburns what
do you got it's no Gallagher everybody
it's a blonde Noel Gallagher alright so
let's get out of it kimete let's run
over this way I heard all about it
this dude needs more sleep and he needs
to moisturize around his eyes
nobody wants crow feet rose feel like
that that's stare okay we're done here
great
alright this dude with a giant coat this
guy looks like I don't want to be a dick
but he looks like he doesn't shower
enough you know I kind of feel like
you're out all day fighting Titans he
got a hygiene is important all this to
make us stronger
all right let's really hoping for some
Titan Fighting Titan fighting guys
anything just John Krasinski looked
directly into the camera on Conan no
needlepoint he doesn't you know what's
funny though is if you go back and you
watch when the situation was on the show
you were the situation the divot he what
he couldn't stop looking at himself in
the monitor it was bananas
I don't know what was going on maybe he
was on a lot of robitussin or something
near the cold medication but he was like
obsessed with it to the point where the
next night we did it thing yeah we Chad
that's gonna put the clip in the check
it's crazy and he looked at I think it's
something like 33 times and like a span
of like 6 minutes
Celgene mania says I think Conan let
magic win and horse so magic will come
back I think no I think magic was just
really good he's one of the greatest NBA
players of all time why do you think
he's gonna be bad
Kota it's gonna be better than him ma'am
uh yeah I was super bummed I didn't get
to go to the magic shoot because it's my
boy from Michigan State Magic Johnson
all right more runnin around you know
just a quick note to the people in
attack on Titan to you know maybe if you
spent some time attacking the effing
Titans instead of just talking to each
other about sideburns and jackets maybe
you could stop them
oh this guy's got a very unfortunate
mustache oh oh this dude is taking some
facial risks and it's not paying off
guys I don't know I don't know what's
happening what's the point of the
computer if comets will barely be read
I don't know d50 Productions that's a
great question
yeah what a sick burn yet I just read
out that's great that clip had some
weird audio yeah well it's the SID
that's just the situation's voice that's
what he just sounds like all right all
right all right
so far 12 minutes in zero Titans fought
Raymond Pierce for playing on the old
ps4 today now let me tell you a quick
these gaming systems have to have some
kind of and now I know I'm gonna get a
bunch of PC is the best but they got to
get some kind of external hard drive
thing going on it's just killing me
because we have to delete all these
games I'm not gonna delete the last of
us save cuz that's dope and I'm because
when the last us two comes out I want to
play the end again oh my god Jesus
Christ what a bunch of crybabies uh so
much this should be just talking at
Titans verbal attack on Titan
[Music]
oh no I don't want to read my journal
goddammit okay yep yep okay get out of
here don't return the beginning get
Jesus Christ get me out of here
what's happening closed please close
close the journal Jamie could be oh I
don't know uh skinny Sam it said the
game actually runs pretty darn well on
switch that's cool
I do love me some switch anybody know
where any Titans are wearing the same
pants in Boots this [ __ ] all right
that good caller big collarbones though
you know what thing I wish I had better
collarbones you know they don't get
enough recognition is like a cool piece
of the body
sonic fear their external drives for ps4
there are Oh sonic fear did you just
change my whole life I think you might
have crybabies well that's a tech attack
on Titan for you guys this Fernando fair
enough Oh Aaron oh there's a person to
Aaron in the game
er en yeah they're not even talking
about me they I immediately took it as
like I was sexy and deflected but nope
alright well we're all talking about
stuff how much money did the attack on
Titan people spend on giant patches for
the back of their jackets look at this
this is crazy everybody's got a giant
patch all there Pat look at what this
guy is like four patches on his jacket
he's got one in the front yeah we get it
everybody's dressed the same like why do
you even oh my god alright yeah tell me
about it buddy oh boy here's so many
something important to say oh good okay
well good we just learned that talking
to someone with a red exclamation point
actually makes the game go faster oh
good we're gonna take a nap
I want is there a way I can play a Titan
in this game cuz I just want to destroy
ya
and everybody Hot Topic sponsors this
needlepoint all right there we have
don't care about this next page it's
great
all right great photo by the way you
could have taken another photo and
mouths open oh my god
you vos says yeah you can come 250 gigs
up to 8 terabytes O'Malley do you hear
that for ps4 8 terabytes upgrade baby
drazi Luis trust me Josie Luis I'm right
there with you oh well that's ok
rain 3:11 says just FYI they're all
dressed the same because they're
soldiers it's called a uniform ok fair
enough but then is every single person
in the town a soldier seems a little
silly by the way
do we all dress like we're the same or
do I have a dope-ass jacket on yeah
somebody's got a bomb-ass jacket and
that's your boy or your girl right here
I think I named her something silly I'm
gonna named her something really stupid
and I'm afraid to look at what it is
they should add a cone and tighten I
agree
or just Conan cousin you know what video
game developers put Conan in a lot of
games they put them into injustice
injustice the first one they put him
into WWE they put him into the MMA the
UFC game and I would love to see them
put a Conan Titan in here it'd be
awesome
soldier blaze is Billy EKKO to me who
cares oh that's right Madeline sim says
I need you're lactose intolerant yeah
yeah that's right
good old lactose lactose is not a bad
girl's name I'm just gonna put it out
there you know like lack okay cool oh
good Wow
all right here we go yeah see this is
what's cool this is why I wanted to get
to oh we got to resupply
all right this is game is about to get
awesome I mean not that talking to
people isn't awesome it's not clueless
Conan you know it
oh look at this dude you gotta get rid
of that guy oh yeah Conan is a Titan
he's exploring various bases all right
you're the bait oh boy okay supply bases
so check this out look at this you could
do like crazy spider-man moves yeah
alright what do I do here build a bait
oh my god fill the base that was easy I
thought it was gonna be like an hour of
building a base
it's his dope no engaging ODM requires
gas don't I know it
I am lactose intolerant by the way so I
mean my name reload blades with yeah
reload those blades
give me some gases thank you the gas
thing nope
[Music]
all right set up a base okay say we
build a base by blah blah I'll press to
keep punishing my items goof on says
she's thinking about reading the movie
you guys got any suggestions patent 2 is
available all right
all right let's restock it
I'll get more gas besides eating a lot
of cheese anybody now let's see here
this man is very strong hips to carry
those things around I know that is one
problem is I think they have problem
going through doorways in this game well
thought Ragnarok was great by the way
really funny Dan shoot for 28 I'm
reading all the comments bro thor
ragnarok says L&R brag okay we reloaded
the things something else I need to do
like I just set this base up pretty well
let's go up to stay up vs stairs let's
go through vertical stairs okay cool
well we've set up the base and now we're
stuck I need new blades bro don't reload
this plate oh here we go got it ooh
there we go look how big these blades
are guys it's not the size of the blades
it's how you use them everybody knows it
all right here we go now we're all
stocked up in blades and gas Marco Marco
constantly wants to set up more bases
Jesus go keep your stupid mouth shut
this is great though it is fun running
around you're more fun running around if
you actually have a reason like you're
fighting giant Titans I would love to
fight a single Titan by the enemies just
one goddamn Titan
alright successfully establish the base
great we got another base feeling good
alright Marco you happy Connie is happy
make for the target area let's go burn
it
Oh God get up I've said before like one
of my favorite games was Incredible Hulk
game because of the way you could run
around like run up buildings and stuff
and this makes me feel the same way
oh yes all right we're gonna attack up
Titan guys I'm very excited oh it's a
dumb wooden Titan medal and wheels
thanks for coming by wait Mars what was
your question
tens are actually humans I don't think
that's true are they are you just
spoiling the game for me I think they're
Titans they said they appeared nobody
knows how direct other team members and
tolerant you're already late hurry up
and get straight right
oh darn it that's right
there we go
look at them all attacking the thing I'd
have to do anything good just stand back
but I don't really seem to be doing much
all right here we go oh I see
I see I'm just supposed to direct from
back here that's boring
I didn't read attack on Titan how is it
you've live a boring Indiana Elinor come
on Andy it is great no problem Indiana
I'm still what toriel and then some what
I look like when is he not that's true
that's but they're right I mean I can't
add Birds waffle tarts
Oh bear ski you son of a [ __ ] I got to
meet Vera ski by the way on Saturday I
took a selfie that was extremely blurry
yeah probably because the nine old
fashions I had okay okay let's see all
right we're gonna do this I keep hitting
them this is why I can't be trusted to
actually like fly a plane or have like
these kinds of things cuz I don't i'm
not good at using stuff all right here
we go
wait dude this right now i would attack
with attack with this nope i attack with
wait just hold on Akane I got this I got
this Connie don't worry about it all
good all good all right we attack with
this we attack no all that weight we
attack with is it circle we tackle
circle
yep circle so when we attack with yep
that's definitely yeah there we go we're
about to attack just do that okay good
we did it and then we do this and let's
have this alright boom good job Marco
all right it's only taking me nine hours
to do this boom take care of that if
you'd be so kind
oh gee Oh a wooden Titan just fell on my
head y'all alright here we go
it's like removing is once and Sasha
yeah it's exactly like removing is one
look at the flow I got going on here
there's no flow guys it's not fight
amongst ourselves
alright this is cool
well I'm terrible at attacking Titans
but my team is great a lot cooler thing
that you have to lock on that's right
now to begin our last training session
but first more talking okay I thought
there's gonna be way more talking I need
to resupply or something it feels like
don't you think it will be supply
situation and I just build as many bases
as I want I guess then game 2f on here
we go
get my gas get my blades that's why you
arguing stop it all right great
oh my god wait we got to kill all these
dumb Titan these dude oh man you know
they're all wooden so it doesn't really
matter all right we lock on we do the
thing and then we just tell other people
to do stuff boom
game is super easy so far by super easy
I mean I'm terrible at it
everybody's arguing what's up guys we
need to have a quick chill sesh these
Titans are tearing our group apart all
right how do we come across this game we
found this because I well I mean the
truth is I do this other thing called
dinner in a video game where I play
video games and cook and I was just
trying to look at a list of video games
and come up with puns and so the best I
could do is a snack on Titan oh and
that's why honestly if I'm being honest
that's why we're playing this game I
made nachos and by the way it turned out
great
except I put cocktail wieners on it and
they were kind of gross but I didn't
give myself food poisoning like I
normally do so that actually hadn't up
being really good oh boy oh no what are
my grades oh yeah it was great lactose
and COEs teamwork is lacking
that's me guys that's on me I think you
should just get unlimited gas just like
in real life you know in this game
they're just talking I'm not paying
attention what I need you to do pisses
are saying because I don't really care
you know yeah
I'm gettin pretty good at this whole
thing out he says as he hits a thing
all right
who said I want to know like what's the
support team setting up these giant
Titans there's got to be an easier way
to train for this right
oh if you didn't live on the East Coast
you'll come yeah thank you I'm hoping to
do more of those live shows it'll be fun
bear ski knows that ice how weird I
smell in real life how awkward I truly
am which is hilarious now you know my
secrets bear ski I into my secrets all
the secrets bad nose yeah yeah I smell
like yeah exactly
it's Seltzer an Old Spice
I do like an Old Spice I was into
swagger for a while it made me feel
swagger II yeah and then I kind of
switched to there was one called like
night moves or night sweats it wasn't
that it was after hours I was wearing
that for a while and then I really liked
a good wolf floorings I thought it made
me smell like a piece of candy but then
people were like why do you smell like
candy and I was like oh because I'm Walt
Thor there we go and then I just wished
a bear glove but them very close sunl
like a weird sex things that stopped
like that yeah I tried that big piece of
salt you ever do that thing where you
put salt under your arms
every time that crystal yeah it's a
thing there's a chrism can back me up on
this chat there's a crystal
antiperspirant crystal thing Britney
right okay well you guys don't know you
guys aren't living anyway now I think
I'm I think I got what's happened today
I think I got ice tobacco and musk yeah
that's that real banner print I like to
branch out with my I have like nine and
deodorants in my house original old
spices I smelled good bear glove for all
your nature needs says Christopher Larry
hey Adrian says why did the second
season attack on Titans Felix
exponentially worsening in the first one
you know why it's the sophomore slump
and here's the fit so they say for all
artists and kind of all things that are
created you know it takes let's say it's
you're a band okay and it takes takes
you five years to get discovered and to
make your first album which is by the
way a very compressed amount of time
yeah your next album takes like a year
like you get popular your first one and
then you got to do what you did in five
years in a year so it's a lot that's
where the sophomore slump comes from is
the fact like your first project it's
you know you've taken the
time and you get to do it the second
project has happened very quick and
that's why you know when you have like a
sequel to a movie or you have something
else like that if the second one's
really good that's very rare that
happens what kind of madman needs 960 of
deodorants his eye guard
well this madman you know it just comes
from a crippling insecurity I have but
also I just liked to smell different
everyday you know mix it up Nicolas Cage
needs all its place I don't that means
and sports team Coco showing new games
in Portugal before internet was the
thing there we go Eureka says she
normally rotates between two brands
because your body goes you've worn this
one a lot so I'm not gonna allow it to
work anymore oh that's a true thing by
the way you actually do need to switch
up your deodorant because your body gets
used to it my body's language my body's
like whoa toes through puberty using
tom's of Maine lavender tom's of Maine
tom's also makes by the way tom's also
makes a great makes it that guy is like
throwing up Tom's makes a good
toothpaste don't think yes I have there
there we go
oh yeah Gingras uses the same thing I'm
allergic to deodorants use the Tom's
unscented Chuck and it's main meaning if
I smoked weed I wouldn't need deodorant
okay well thanks for that you know it's
funny it's my mom got me when I was in
college in Michigan she got me like for
Christmas incense for my room I'd I'm
not a big weed smoker and I didn't smoke
back then but she got me
cannabis sentences now quick question
quick Q what's the point of that if
you're burning incense to cover weed why
would you have weed incense doesn't make
any sense to me doesn't make any sense
I guess you could say Oh
like then when the Aria comes in like
what's going on in here you're like oh
it's my cannabis incense
anyway waffles art says guys say never
thought says big stream discussion will
be about deodorant I love it what
deodorant is every now here's the thing
let's say like are we really into like
do we like this
normal deodorant or do you like weird
smells I'm kind of into weird smells
like let's do like a new car smell you
know let's do like a burnt plastic let's
do like a you know like our weird
combinations you know like I like the
ice tobacco and musk I don't know what
it smells like it smells like terrible
but I like I bought it because I was
like this is interesting you know like
you have a candle like a rum a therapy
is a big thing people buy these crazy
candles it's like cinnamon and birthday
cake and all these like ridiculous
[ __ ] things why can't we do that
with the odorant you could be a walking
around therapy candle guys you can
provide yes exactly
lafawn says no in the print plastic all
right needle points this quote I'm kinda
into weird smells but I am that's right
what's and smells good it says it's him
I agree with that you know what here's a
bad thing which is I once bought and
this is Los Angeles I bought and this
was dumb as a joke a twenty dollar dirt
scented candle and it said dirt on it
was like hahaha
there's no way this smells like dirt
right this is such a funny thing and had
like a little horse on top oh my god
this is so good smelled exactly like
dirty and like it like it smelled like
compost so when people come into my
apartment it smelled like there was just
something rotting and normally which
there is by the way and so maybe it's
kind of like the cannabis it's kind of
like the cannabis incense in which kind
of smells like mildew in here it's like
well it's my mildew candle it's not the
fact I live in a crappy apartment staff
booster just Conan smell weird
Conan smells we're back in the [ __ ]
town ha ha ha uh Conan smells honestly
like sometimes he smells like leather
because he wears his leather jacket all
the time
he smells like old parchment you know
like if you go like if you were to open
that case that the Constitution is is
kept in and by the way don't do that
kids'll be arrested probably shot to
death I think you would smell like like
the Magna Carta you never the
Constitution just the thought of old
parchment is making Beth okay
guys I'm not into talking I'm into
killing Titans all right okay all right
okay oh there we go awesome that's great
cuz just watching your hair yeah leather
and parchment Conan Pookie man might be
a mummy we're not sure he does Russell
he sounds like shuffling papers when he
walks down the hall I think that's just
cause he's super thin he doesn't
moisturize his hair made of old
parchment no I think I mean I mean it's
made of human hair but it's a wig a lot
of 100 that he's balding mm-hmm many
people don't know that Conan's fault
he's like one of those witches if you
ever seen Rahl doll oh yeah yeah he's
basically anjelica huston yeah what is
that what does that call the witches
aren't there like itchy scalps I
remember that when I was a kid okay
nothing game so far
I think tutorials should be not
obligatory like this is boring I mean I
get it I understand the story and all
that but like just you know like let me
just dive in and fight some Titans like
what are you doing hey but I know again
I'm not a huge fan of the anime so it's
hard for me I think people who really
like the anime are probably like oh this
is cool I get to play my favorite
character for me I'm like you know the
Box had giant Titans on it
I started out funny and giant Titan I'm
not gonna talk to any of these people
because I don't care I just want to go
fight giant Titans pretty cone and I
blast
shampoos be used I don't use shampoo I
let my hair self clean it's not what do
you miss out of me I'm just trying it
out
I'm just trying it out you know it's a
neat thing I've been doing for the past
rest of my life since I was born
thanks Michael Mitch Mitchell I was
almost at the Plaza area reminds me of
the Italian street where Aaron was
streaming behind the scenes for Facebook
there we go yeah friends a friend's
house ever you say it would you be able
to see that's right two weeks from today
yes yes two weeks from today our Italy
episode no wait a second needle oh click
Adelphia says no the anime it's about
Titans Neil Boyd says it works after
about a month or natural oils balance
themselves out I don't believe that but
I'd like to I know I shampoo my beard
also every day cuz it's under my nose
it's hair and you know if you eat
something with a beard you got a sauce
let's say you're eating some kind of a
wing you know like a hot wing yeah let's
say you eat some kind of a brisket let's
say you got some kind of clam chowder
New England not that New York red crap
alright get out of here with your
[ __ ] I don't care about that maybe
eating out of a bread bowl maybe you go
to slurp it up and then it gets in your
face and now you smell like clam chowder
for the rest of the day and your ice
tobacco and musk scent from your armpits
can't waft up enough to make it not
smell like that that's why you gotta
shampoo your beard I hate this by the
way oh it's mustache guy how's your
how's your porn shoot coming back oh god
this guy I have not played Far Cry 5 yet
Zenvo but I want to Louie Louie Medrano
says wait hold on Conan as a wig yes he
does
I want that out there Conan's got a wig
he's totally bald spread that rumor guys
this is your assignment I'm gonna turn
this into like Fight Club or Project
Mayhem
just start putting Conan on blast
everybody your assignment is to go make
a piece of graffiti that says come
where's away I'm gonna take down the
shell from the inside like I've been
doing for the past thousand years my
nightmare
what's your nightmare April O'Neill by
the way my favorite Ninja Turtle
character second only to Casey Jones
third only to Raphael yeah he's the one
with the son you know he's the cool oh
my god what's happening I'm buying
something
oh yeah that's right
that was a piece we gave out is it
common knowledge were remember that
meeting we had in the big conference
room is that kind of knowledge they had
the first floor yesterday very cryptic
sorry I don't know I I'm privy to a lot
of information and I'm I don't know when
to let it out and so yeah we're planning
a lot of cool big stuff coming out stuff
I can't talk about clearly and oh my god
please please end this and this
nightmare I am guys should we play 15
more minutes of this or should we play
call I and played a game called
oxen-free
I'm trapped in the regiment store some
of you know this is just we play oxen
free like you bastard you tell us that's
right
burski says don't throw out challenges
and I know some dope street artists
awesome no let it out that's what play
the other game says Eureka I'm basically
like four deep Ludo no I'm whatever
Saints which socks are free aren't good
all right thank you guys thank God we
can also play Friday the 13th as we all
know that's I feel like every strain
just ends
with us playing Friday the 13th because
it's so great well the last time I tried
to play it a lot of people aren't
playing that game anymore because
they're all playing for tonight
RG the barbarians has played sin
rancagua peachy Beach splash is that a
thing Paddington or did I just is that
our though is that the activation code
for the Winter Soldier that you've just
had me a bunch of words and that's Stan
Sebastian's gonna go crazy Lainie
Maribel says is my first time watching a
Coco livestream I love the gameplay but
the chat is weird that's true we got
some weird people that Japanese y'all
weird do I have a a whiff oh you might
mean a wife or it could be a wiffle ball
maybe they just stopped
they stopped yeah I think this shirt I
think this shirt should answer that this
shirt and this watch can we just get in
here on this polka dot watch I'm an
adult by the way and I'm wearing this
watch that's a problem all right
oxen-free is taking forever to load if
you want some Kosan as you said you want
some quantum one equality Japanese game
I suggest you play okay Okami HD it's
not a game of pure art so you just said
if you want a game play this but it's
not a game it's art so what is it dude
is it orders of the game gotcha caught
you in your own lie Conan's better than
me that's true
and richer and only slightly taller
though he's only got an inch on me I
have a whiff that's true yes that's
right polka dots confirmed oh it's new
oh it's oh it's new york says oh you
have an idea for a video game nice try
nice try pathetic I'm not giving away my
yeah I do though you want to hear it
it's called Friday the 14th it's called
Saturday the 14th that's what happens
then the day after Friday the Friday the
13th game it's a sequel and it's it
takes place at Camp it's a summer camp
simulator and so basically just like a
fun time at the can
but then there's just bodies everywhere
because you know Jason I'm killing
everybody so you got it it's partially
like a body cleanup game you know and
it's also partially a summercamp game
and it's also partially like a farming
simulator game cuz when we played
farming simulator 2015 that was super
fun yeah like yes it's like I like
driving one of those what's this what is
this what's this thing what's this thing
that farmers drive yeah like a John
Deere that's a John Deere makes a lot of
a tractor I would know I was thinking
about no it's this thing what's this
thing okay we're just playing charades
what's it this thing what's this thing
why are you driving like this and it
goes like this a thresher yes please
don't this is cool I like this game this
is oxen free and the timing had just
never worked out a combine sorry but
it's also a thresher right a thresher on
a combine on the same thing a tractor so
what's a thresher we've gone from
deodorants straight into farm equipment
guys happy hunted but a thresher is a
thing right his oxen free a game
available for free and to the end of the
month to twitch prime subscribers there
we go is that Zenith wheel this is
supposed to be really scary by the way
willing to reach the food on the top
shelf now oh this is cool
oh we could do different stuff on the
ship all right here we go so I'm the
girl with the blue hair I'm into the new
trend where people are dyeing their hair
different colors potato blogs I love
this oh the lights are on the ship where
are we going you guys it gets really
spooky suspend ring age ooh I love
spooky I by the way I'm more scared by
spooky than I am by scary you know like
somebody jumps out like Google's Jersey
doesn't scare me like The Shining you
know like The Shining where like they're
all dressed up it's a good you've been
here forever mr. Torrance like ooh she's
been correctly got that's that stuff
scares me hardcore to the point where I
was so scared by The Shining when I saw
twister you guys have seen the movie
twister shining is in the shining is in
twister there's a point where they go to
a drive-in and they're the twins they're
like improve us I was like they checked
me what color hair do I wish I can rock
I'm happy with this hair I mean I can't
change it I've tried to change it back
in the day
Conan actually Conan dyed my hair orange
in the center and the side with this was
all brown he shaved off one of my
eyebrows they shaved a patch here and
put a postage stamp there and he shaved
to see in the back of my head yeah it
was for a remote he didn't just do that
because I was an intern so when people
say oh are you upset that he hit hits
you I'm like well least he's not
screwing my hair up do I thank you his I
don't know what that means stat booster
lady in the background will you also
play sorry by the way for calling you
like that I just can't tell who you are
with that tiny face cam first of all I'd
like to consider myself a pretty lady as
well so I think you're kind of referring
to both of us
but I heard names Beth Ann no she's not
yeah and I'm gonna put my head forward
so you could tell that I would make a
good lady okay that's enough she was
like maybe the biggest no I've ever
heard there's a thing what's happening
here this is blinking but I'm not seeing
anything oh here we go
oh cool hey a mouse can you put us up in
that upper left
or some spooky like the world's ending
[ __ ] I love your hair but would you mind
changing it well I guess you don't love
it then human horse do you and human
horse
aren't you just a centaur isn't that a
human horses happy
we need you're going to get like an SOS
like a help me who's gonna see ready
player one this weekend I love the book
and I hear the movies dope and I pulled
any pranks on Conan sizzla Shanta's
Washington ah no but Conan likes to pull
pranks on me and I'll tell you a quick
one and this is kind of what people are
like you know Conan is is also hilarious
as you would imagine in real life and
once we were having tea we're in Florida
we're having dinner and it was me and
Conan in two other people and we're at a
nice restaurant and you know we get up
to leave I had to pay I'm just kidding
you think and get to leave and there's
like as we're leaving there's this nice
huge stench of these beautiful flowers
like in the middle of this thing and
he's kind of walking ahead of me and he
goes he smells the flowers he goes oh my
god he goes bleh come here smell this
and I was like ok and I go and I smell
the flower and then he kind of keeps
walking and I'm smelling the flower and
like I'm like like oh and like maybe
I'll smell one of the other ones maybe I
was like I'm like smelly another when I
can't smell it I've got my face like in
the flowers I like and I just I just
look and he's outside he just laughing
because they were plastic they were
flowers he was dying laughing yeah so
that's him for yeah that's great
so yes he pranks me but you know I can't
prank my boss what's a prank that you
guys would what what's a prank that I
should pull on Conan and maybe I'll try
to do it
what's a prank anybody got a good prank
we're a different kind of deodorant
anybody it would have been funny of
water squirted out yeah thanks
yeah Conan the prankster yeah he got me
good man Conan smells like flowers has
been Oldenburg yeah if flowers were made
of leather and paper pull his wig oh
that's funny it's more oh Medrano pull
his wig that's really funny
Matt wasn't caught in a prankster in
college you got to get him on a good one
yeah make a play D&D and have fun being
polite
take the razors off at tremor trimmer
and cut his hair off but not really
because he's worth it says Garnier
Fructis although I would think I'm
worried about like catching his hair in
something put his sinuses you must be
this tall that or the studio and have it
shorter than everyone played okay posted
elf spotting certificate up on his door
he already has the Gettysburg Address on
his door yeah when he got a typewriter
he typed it out and put it on his matter
he's a weird history nerd settle the
clocks ahead three hours that's pretty
good
I'm into this game by the way and I want
to play it when I don't have to also
read two chats trip him again like on
the gum and hair that's gonna get me
fired pickup from Portugal Avery no I
don't get the sick ass job super jelly
well this part of the job is taupe girl
other parts aren't as good like having
to wash Conan's hair every night his
week I'm sorry I take it home with me in
my bag in my backpack then I wash it and
bring it back
click Adelphia sorry no actually and
that's actually not funny yeah actually
felt on her himself so no I'm not gonna
do that make him live with George
slansky for a week he did that to
himself
yeah when we went to Italy and you're
gonna be able to see that on April 11
primetime baby and we're gonna have a
whole host of amazing digital extras for
you guys it's gonna be great and I have
to say I'm very excited about I'm very
excited about the Continental EF I said
because it's Jordan is hilarious Jordan
and Conan are hilarious you get to see
my favorite thing is like when you work
here for a little while or if you watch
a lot of our show you can they're like
Conan it's hard to make Conan work crack
to make Conan like break up you know cuz
he's a professional but he cracks so
many times this episode because Jordan
legitimately makes him laugh yeah like
he thinks or drives him crazy so there's
so many like it's a real it's a great
episode for us who work here as well
because it's like Conan laughing for
real it's not a real [ __ ] and we were
all there was points in the Italy
episode where we were filming the only
thing I was weeping what laughter like
tears are coming down my face like if
you saw our Instagram where he makes
Jordan like put his head in this
Pinocchio thing oh yeah it makes fun of
him I was laughing so hard I was crying
I was crying laughing
do a close game with Kenema give him a
dummy control and control his character
while hidden with the actual controller
this is Sean ruck I mean sometimes I you
know I have to play for him anyway so I
know that that would be a great make
Conan drink eat and drink soda in a bag
of popcorn I don't think he's gonna do
that it's gotta be a prank I could
surprise him with because he's just
gonna say no I'm not listening to
anything these people are saying Jordan
cracking during the interview bit was
amazing yeah it's true get ready for
more I mean like it's so good maybe let
Beth play for a while she doesn't look
like yeah it's true you look like a fool
I was dying
hey relax hey Coco is upstairs is that
doki-doki literature Club what's the PhD
what's the game I'm thinking of three oh
I had to open the thing again wait I
have to open
throwing our waters or something like
that it's propeller was the one thing
recovered so doki-doki literature club
yeah but you have to play through the
entire game first I tried to play that
game and it was way too boring so I quit
the expert noob doesn't doki-doki take
late
don't take like 4 hours yeah the expert
noob it takes you have to play the
entire game through before it gets crazy
conan comes to Vegas while Conan I don't
know I mean I guess
Zenda that's a great question peace out
bear ski kanischev a book club it's we
tried to do that kind of called jibber
jabber it turned into Conan just
interviewing presidential historians do
be played he games together off screen
says extra moist no we played space team
a lot when I first came out in the
office yeah we actually team cocoa and
bowling
yeah real an IRL game guys dream island
yeah my first round I guess like Beth
lose a killer
I'm terrible bullying you know we
bowling destroyed my bowling yes we
bowling killed it cuz I used to be okay
at bowling but then it's like with the
controller you're just like you know
yeah and sorry I never got my farm back
really sucks
yes I could say so Finn you're exactly
right well anyone prove cunning wrong
how they would sing 57 ah that's a good
question I don't know I hope somebody
does someday then he'd like disappear
you know it'd be like like a pixie dust
I don't know I'm talking about pixie
dust find a candle that smells like
farts
now we're talking faux sex oh that's a
prank you gotten it stay hydrated by ah
yes that is a prank oh it's a standard
but because it's one o'clock yeah
exactly a diuretic exactly uh that's
gonna do it for us guys the game we just
played was oxen-free we start off
playing attack on Titan - I mean we'll
get a little further than that off
screen so we can actually fight yes
exactly
make sure to watch our show tonight we
got the great Ed Helms on we have the
breeders on who are on Conan's 11th show
which is amazing
they're back that's right miles Brown
from blackish which also stars one of
our good friends Deon Cole which is
great
make sure watch the show tonight this
game is like a free attack outside
- see you guys next week see you later
bye
[Music]